c'est dans cette délicate plante le
crocus sativus que se cache le safran
une précieuse ep surnommé l' en rouge
dans l'affluence ce qui est la partie
safran c'est quoi c'est le pistil oh que
c'est le pistil de la flac et la partie
safran nathalie de nous est une
pionnière elle cultive le safran au
québec depuis 2012
aujourd'hui on compte environ 25
producteurs québécois parce qu'ils
étaient en un c'est que on puisse faire
pousser du safran ici au québec si avait
pas de neige au québec on pourrait pour
faire de safran la neige apporte une
couche de protection à cette plante
pendant nos froid hiver mais c'est à
l'automne que cette plante fleurie alors
actuellement c'est la période de la
récolte en octobre et novembre
on ne les feuillages qui sort de terre
et les fleurs vous avez combien de temps
pour lui récolté les fleurs sont
éphémères ne vivent généralement que 24
à 48 heures mais dans les premiers 24
heures ok les flammes dans la même
journée on doit parler montage et le
séchage les transformer en voilà un
travail de précision qui demande doigté
et patience sur le marché le safran se
vend généralement entre 13 et 20 dollars
le gramme
celui de pure safran 55 dollars
berkshire votre sauveur écoute c'est sûr
que ça fera en iran qui - charles dance
dans les conditions où le salaire est
moins cher l'iran export 170 tonnes de
safra soit 90% de la production mondiale
nathalie elle avec ses vingt mille
plants ne produit que 200 g
nous avons présenté le safran québécois
à 2 iranienne d'origine et mais là et sa
fille nina
ouais ça sent en effet ça sent très bon
c'est pas des iraniens par hasard ce
sont des québécois
les deux femmes sont les propriétaires
du byblos véritable institution depuis
trente ans sur le plateau mont royal
chez nous on peut pas envisager un plan
sciences à fond à oui parce que c'est
vraiment
la première odeurs leur île le sens le
riz mais avec la petite odeur de safran
en plus sinon c'est pas dur y règne dans
ce restaurant on peut aussi déguster une
confiture et des desserts safrané il
faut beaucoup d'argent
il faut qu'ils sachent 600 mg et la
partage avec nous sa technique pour
faire hemani saveurs et couleurs du
safran d'abord en fin les apprendre mais
quand un peu de ce qu'on peut voir bien
le mode rebond à temps mais l'eau chaude
pour le diluer il faut que ce soit un
rouge assez assez foncée quand même et
si ce liquide safrané qui est ensuite
utilisées pour parfumer les plans
nathalie utilisent elles une méthode
différente
le safran n'est pas une épice instantané
c'est une épice qui a besoin d'être
réhydrater et une se réhydrate ans
qu'elle libère son parfum son arôme sa
couleur elle fait infuser un à deux
pistes il par portions et ce pour un
minimum d'une à quatre heures s'appelle
dans l'alcool dans le vin blanc dans la
crème dans les dents ça peut dans de
l'eau le safran color un genre donc la
couleur de l'or moi je congèle des
infusions pour pas avoir à le faire une
heure quatre heures avant à chaque fois
que j'ai envie de quelque chose de
safran n'était pas une bonne idée
puis qu'est-ce que vous aimez faire avec
le zafira cuisine ou dans n'importe
quelle recette du quotidien dans les
potages élan mais aussi dans les
biscuits en fait une limonade des
vinaigrettes et des moutardes tout
semble se marier à cette épice au goût
unique difficilement descriptible c'est
soit tu sais c'est un peu mielleux salle
une certaine amertume aussi c'est un
mélange de tout ça mais c'est un
armateur de sa valeur sur le marché
en plus du safran québécois iranienne et
espagnol vous trouverez du safran
américain à un prix dérisoire 55 le
gramme c'est quoi ça sera mérité
lesaffre américain en fait ne contient
aucun safran c'est bien indiqué que ces
deux-là fleurs de carthage
qui rien à voir avec le safran sel ni la
couleur ni le parfum niels harrit facile
de reconnaître le vrai safran une des
extrémités et toujours aplatit c'est
encore les pêcheurs ont manqué ses
débuts sa plus précieuse eau précieuse
on en utilise tellement peu quand l'un
safran de qualité que en bout de ligne
c'est pas plus cher qu'un autre que
notre ep sous qu'un autre herbe pour
aromatiser parfumée et colorée avec un
pouvoir incroyable magique qu' aucune
autre et pièces ou qu'il ya aucun autre
et à rien d'autre qui est comparable
pour 50 66 par portion
[Musique]